as this generation continues its fight
against the coronavirus
concerns are growing about the next
generation
some like this medical worker are
staying on the front lines
despite being pregnant
others are putting off their dreams of
parenthood until a treatment can be
found
some had predicted a baby boom during
lockdown
but initial research suggests u.s birth
rates have fallen
that leaves many wondering what
long-term effects covet 19
could have on fertility rates
[Music]
some of my friends have been through
stressful times others have coasted
through this crisis
making the most of taking it easy during
pregnancy and many more
are delaying their plans to make a
family google searches for terms like
morning sickness and pregnancy tests
have fallen
scientists say the data collected point
to a 15
drop in birth rates in the united states
in the coming months
the picture varies around the world but
all in all it looks like
fewer babies a higher impact on the
well-being of new moms
and effects on older generations further
down the track
a month before this moment maria alvarez
lost her husband to the coronavirus
herself infected but asymptomatic
she gave birth in a peruvian hospital
surrounded by doctors whose faces she
could not recognize behind their
protective gear
it's just one experience of giving birth
during a pandemic
for most women the conditions will be
far less tragic
but still researchers believe the
coronavirus could have an impact on
family planning
with women choosing to delay having
children while the virus
and the economic uncertainty that
accompanies it continues to rain
this could intensify an already worrying
downward trend in the global birth rate
for the past several decades fertility
rates worldwide have been in decline
but there are major regional differences
in niger for instance the average woman
will still give birth to seven children
in her lifetime
in germany it's less than two
that has given rise to grave concerns
about society's readiness to provide for
rising numbers of elderly people
whose pensions need to be financed by an
ever-shrinking workforce
the problem is already well known in
japan where one in four people
are over the age of 65.
experts say previous pandemics like the
spanish flu in 1918
provide only limited clues about what to
expect this time
the global birth rate did fall in 1919
but this was followed by a baby boom the
following year
usually attributed to the end of world
war one
it's far from certain whether a similar
boom could follow the coronavirus
the pace of an economic recovery and the
search for a vaccine are both likely to
play a role
but demographic trends are one thing and
personal stories
another holding a healthy baby girl in
her
arms for maria alverez memories of
giving birth during a pandemic will
forever be laced
with both tragedy and hope let's talk
about making babies with
natalie nietzsche a fertility researcher
at germany's max planck institute
natalie will birth rates really fall
because a lot of people have had
a lot of time on their hands during
lockdown
yeah i know i read the media reports as
well and while i'm sure
there will be some lockdown babies born
that as a major trend to affect
future fertility rates is extremely
unlikely and
i would say yes birth rates are going to
fall
at least in the next few years or in the
next year
let me tell you a bit more about why i
think yeah
i was just going to say we're talking
globally i guess uh are
are there differences between poorer and
richer nations
most likely we will see differences uh i
was just about to talk about the higher
income countries for example europe
north america
australia in those countries we are
seeing
the lockdowns we are seeing recessions
and we also know from previous research
that
pandemics and recessions cause fertility
to fall at least for a while so some
studies have been conducted that
asked people across european countries
on their fertility planning
and the great majority were planning for
in 2019 said that during the lockdown
they have changed their mind and they
are now either postponing
the baby-making and these plans
altogether there's a few minority of
people that said
they changed their mind and they wanted
a baby now but this is just a small
portion of couples
are these changes or trends likely to
become
permanent
well uh that's a very difficult question
uh nothing is permanent in fertility so
that's one of the features
it's it's constantly changing along with
social change
um you know classically af sessions or
pandemics when fertility
fell it has rebounded after about one
two three
to two or three years but what happened
after the last recession we had the
great recession in o8 was that fertility
rates
fell and kept falling until basically
today in some countries at least like
the nordic countries or the u.s
which has puzzled fertility researchers
to begin with and now this pandemic is
falling on top of declining
birth rates in some high-income
countries
and it's unclear how the trends will
actually look like longer term the
reason i'm asking is because
a lot of people believe this planet is
full
and what's happened now with this
pandemic
is um we've had social distancing and
people realizing uh
we need even more space and uh
you know the question is whether or not
we have that
well you know um that's of course
interesting
uh and i think there are a couple of
factors that we are right now discussing
that will likely have an impact on
fertility and the social distancing i
think
is something we can't really measure the
effects of yet but we can think about
that
and of course for baby making physical
contact is necessary and
we are thinking that fertility will be
impacted
by changes in relationship for example
single people who
are not finding partners perhaps right
now or couples
that split up after the stresses of the
lockdown
that will likely have have have effects
on fertility that we can't really say
how they will look like
now you you mentioned the physical
uh effects what about the mental and
emotional factors involved
yes mental health has been impacted
negatively
by the measures and the lockdown and
there is a correlation
between mental health and fertility
which is a negative one
so that could go through the union
formation or through the
the partnership stresses that could also
decrease the interest in having a child
to begin with
it's not clear how the direction of this
effect looks like
but i think it will it will play a role
in future fertility also you asked about
the global impacts and i think what is
going to be really important
in predicting how fertility will develop
in
the the lower income countries is how
the culture
of these countries will provide perhaps
a filter
that moderates how the recession and the
health effects
of the pandemic will affect fertility
for example
i'm thinking about things like like risk
taking or emotional coping
that could be handled differently and by
the populations on average in these
countries
and there's very little research on that
and we are attempting to look into this
into the future
in our research from germany's max
planck institute thank you very much
good talking to you
let me hand you over to our science
correspondent derek williams he's been
looking into some of your questions
on the coronavirus
in an electron microscope sars cove 2
and flu viruses look alike
they both have a corona
so why isn't flu a coronavirus too
i understand your confusion maybe it
makes the most sense to explain
by drawing a comparison from the macro
world that we live in
um sparrows for instance have have wings
and they have beaks and they have
feathers
um and so do eagles would you would you
call them the same thing
you can't judge evolutionary
relationships
based on just one or two apparently
shared
traits in virological terms although
influenza and coronaviruses are both
single-stranded
rna viruses that that bear spikes on
their outer surfaces
that's pretty much where the
similarities
end the coat that surrounds that genetic
material and the two groups is
is for example made up of very different
proteins which which interact also
differently with our cells and and that
genetic material itself
is very different coronaviruses are much
larger than flu viruses and their rna is
made up of around
30 000 base pairs in a single long
strand that's more than twice as many as
make up the influenza genome which
which consists of sort of several
distinct segments
the way the two species replicate inside
of our cells is also
different and and flu mutates a lot
faster
so so don't be fooled by appearances uh
coronaviruses
and influenza viruses are two to very
distinct groups without a lot in common
other than a vague visual resemblance in
an electron microscope and the fact that
they both cause
respiratory infections
[Music]
i thought eagles and sparrows were
pretty much alike i know they're birds
and i know we're full of viruses well
just finally before i let you go
churches
are open again for mass in the capital
of the democratic republic of congo
but with a few new covert 19 inspired
rituals
at this church in kanchasa priests and
religious leaders walk through a
decontamination tent and wear face masks
and shields
more services are being offered to allow
for fewer people at each service
parishioners are encouraged to wash
their hands upon entering where masks
and social distance even in the pews
in south korea and many other countries
churches have been criticized for
causing so-called super spreader events
where dozens
in some cases hundreds of people have
gotten sick
from an infected individual by
comparison
the average coronavirus patient infects
just two other people
you